hey leute und willkommen zu einer späten
sieht review heute abend in der version
1.3.1 wir wohl ein neuer sieht
zugesendet der typ der medizin
zugesendet hat steht jetzt auch übrigens
immer mitten unten in der beschreibung
damit er dadurch auch noch ein wenig
gepusht wird danke übrigens an dich der
sieg des extremst geil creator mir mal
eben hier so eine neue world so den sieg
gebe ich ein create new world der
senioren in der beschreibung also könnt
ihr euch einfach da unten schon raus
kopieren bei euch rein kopieren und dann
läuft das export hier in seinem
verpackten dschungel also ich mag schon
mal nicht so gerne allerdings müsst ihr
so ein bisschen raus laufen bzw fliegen
also ist da läuft hier so rum und ich
weiß dieser sieg hat keine tollen
landschaften roh kakaobohnen das ist ja
schön aber das ist nicht das haupt
feature sondern das hier ist einerseits
cool denn wir haben hier eine sanduhr
ami de berichtet mich wenn ihr es besser
wissen
da können wir erst mal reingehen da ist
allerdings sind das nicht so besondere
sachen drin wir gehen hier erstmal rein
hier findet ihr was zu essen paar
knochen ein paar gold ingots und noch
mehr also wirklich viel fressen könnten
ja mal spaßeshalber das war nicht extra
ich bin da drauf gefallen
das kohle
naja das ist nicht das haupt feature
dieses sieht sondern was das ist ein
fehler
das hier ist das haupt feature höhe das
ist doch ein ganz normales dorf ja ja
das denkt ihr
im moment wartet man hier was die beiden
so trocken dass schon vor und zwar in
solchen china schmieden findet man ja
manchmal ganz interessante sachen das
ist interessant findet in diesen dingen
9 diamanten und teilt 21 plates aber
viel geiler finde ich diese neuen
diamanten kommen könnte ich könnte euch
diamanten kommt zurück gut also findet
hier echt diamanten 39 diamanten auf
einmal ich habe so etwas noch nie
gesehen dass ich in einer truhe ich habe
vielleicht mal einen diamanten gefunden
oder so aber nie 9 auf einmal dass es
schon immens kraft ich glaube vielmehr
gibt es doch gar nicht zu entdecken aber
noch eine ganz interessante sache ist
dass da wirklich ein dschungel ist hier
ist eine wüste
dass schnee direkt an der wüste gibt es
auch selten da hinten so normale region
da so ein bisschen flachland und ja also
das coolste war wirklich etwas dieser
neuen diamanten darauf einmal drin sind
also das hat mir den tipp auch
geschrieben dass das vielleicht mal eine
andere etwas andere motto review wieder
etwas kürzer habe ich sie schon ich habe
schon wieder zwei minuten 30 gelabert
und wo ich eigentlich nur sagen wollte
dass es hier diamanten gibt in dieser
schmiede der südstadt in der
beschreibung also wenn ihren tollen
anfänger sieht braucht macht das auf
jeden fall gibt den einen toten bisschen
überrascht sowohl das sind 9 jemanden
das hätte ich jetzt überhaupt nicht
gedacht
naja und teilt die pyramide da könnt ihr
auch noch ein bisschen durchforsten oder
der etwas tolles tor ausbauen
dann würde ich sagen mit diesem tollen
blick auf diese wunderbare schmiede und
alte dessen see das ist ja cool würde
ich sagen wir sehen uns in der nächsten
zeit review wenn ihr mir das übrigens
noch eine coole schlucht fällt mir dazu
auf habe ich gar nicht vorhergesehen
wenn ihr wieder kulisse ist einfach
unten in die kommentare schreiben und es
ist vielleicht eure chance nächstes mal
und in der beschreibung zu stehen dass
sie dran kommt usw muss bis zum nächsten
mal ich würde mich über ein daumen hoch
von und ich wünsche mir dabei mich eine
halbe stunde genau eine halbe stunde
eine halbe minute lang zu verabschieden
also kann ich mich theoretisch jetzt
noch länger verabschieden also ich sagte
damals schaue ich finde das wetter
gerade echt elendig heißt bei uns ins 33
grad aber das interessiert eh kein
schwein ich hab neuen diamanten
bis zum nächsten mal